and I would say things like schools
difficult schools boring no it isn't the
reason that asked me to speak because
one of my more successful shows was one
at ABC called stupid in America that
inflamed the Union and raised the idea
of choice and since then so much has
happened this is one area or we can say
wow finally Goodwin's actually one of
the reasons I left ABC was because I
wanted to update stupid in America and
talk about choice hey there's a whole
movement now this show which did well is
it gonna do even better cuz will this
new stuff has happened now you're
predictable and then we want to you know
have Portland's story we have to do and
I did Michael Jackson still dead and so
I left and we did another one at Fox and
four I went to a fourth-grade class at a
charter school and in my kids private
school in New York City where we pay
$25,000 tuition most of the fourth
graders are act you know alert and eager
learn and I go into this Harlem fourth
grade classroom and I would say nearly
all of them seemed alert and eager to
learn and I would say these things like
schools difficult schools boring no it
isn't
they were verbal and this school was
doing something right and I don't
presume to know what part of choice
worked in this case they're in school
longer they're there they feel these
kids need extra structures so they have
Saturday classes and they go till five
o'clock maybe it's that the teachers
wear an earpiece and sometimes a master
teacher comes in sits in the back of the
hall and make suggestions while they're
teaching I don't know but the great
thing about choice is that these winning
experiments will emerge you know more of
these flowers will bloom and that's
great the only other thing I want to add
is that it shows how horrible things
were that it took this long for this
eminently sensible thing to happen and
if you think about it all we're asking
for with vouchers that the money be
attached to the kid and in America it's
about thirteen thousand bucks so it's
two hundred fifty thousand twenty could
to it the money that shows how that
monopoly squanders it but having the
money attached to the kid paid for by
the government is basically single payer
so what we reject in healthcare we're
now cheering that we finally got to in
education and that shows how screwed up
that was